bonjour à cames nafti merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur arte france
qu'elle saïd persiste et signe comment
est-ce que vous accueillez son annonce
de maintenir le gel du parlement on va
dire que cette annonce était plutôt
attendu depuis depuis un certain temps
il a il envoyait à pas mal de signes
durant tout ce mois pour dire que
le gel du parlement serait prolongée
alors il n'a pas dit aussi directement
que ça mais c'était attendu donc il a
attendu l'âge eux le soir dit hier très
tard juste avant minuit pour communiquer
ça sur un sapin sur la page facebook de
la présidence de la république mais ce
n'est pas une grande surprise
kaïs saïd a les pleins pouvoirs mais il
le dit c'est selon lui au nom de la
lutte contre la corruption aux grands
maux les grands remèdes
oui c'est visiblement ce qu'il ce qu'il
entend ce qu'il entend faire c'est à
dire que il a laissé quelque part la
situation s'aggraver pendant pendant des
mois notamment avec la gestion
catastrophique du gouvernement de chichi
de la crise du coc vide donc plus de
20000 personnes autour de 21 21 mille
morts duo kobe d' un ras-le-bol général
et
l'absence une absence de stratégie
claire donc pour l'instant il dispose
d'un soutien populaire très important
ce qui lui permet effectivement de de
continuer cet état d'exception mais en
entend de plus en plus de voix
s'émouvoir d'une possible dérive
autoritaire donc c'est à surveiller pour
l'instant il est largement appuyée par
la population un sondage de la semaine
dernière faisait état de plus de 95%
94 par des opposants de l'adhésion à ces
à ces décisions c'est du jamais vu ça
veut dire que la population compteront
que kaïs saïd veut éradiquer la
corruption c'est ça
mais vous dites que certaines voix
commencent à s'élever vis-à-vis d'une
dérive potentiellement autoritaire
lesquels et et
quand on dit dérive autoritaire ça
voudrait dire quoi vous dire à avoir
peur pour les libertés individuelles
c'est ça
absolument c'est à dire que la
actuellement nous sommes dans une
situation où le président de la
république détient quasiment l'essentiel
du pouvoir il ya plus de parlement donc
il y gouverne par décrets il ya plus de
premier ministre depuis un mois donc il
est
ministre et parlement a lui-même et même
le 25 juillet quand il a déclaré les
mesures exceptionnelles il a laissé
entendre qu'il serait le chef du parquet
donc quelque part qui voulait aussi
avoir la main sur le service sur le
système judiciaire bon il a rétropédalé
sur ce dernier point mais aujourd'hui et
concentre les pouvoirs et tout passe
tout si sa volonté donc on n'entend
évidemment les islamistes qui qui ont
perdu le lead qu'ils avaient sur
l'assemblée et même sur la vie sur la
vie politique dont il est tout à fait
logique qu'il proteste encore qu' ils
ont mis 6 juste si j'ose dire les
islamistes du parti ennahda majoritaire
à l'assemblée
ce sont eux que vise qu'à essayer de nom
quand il parle de corruption
je pense qu'ils les vices peu mais pas
seulement c'est à dire qu'il ya une
corruption qui est généralisé les dix
dernières années
on va effectivement des liens avec avec
des personnes notoirement corrompu mais
je pense qu'il va même au delà de ça et
donc que les islamistes protestent c'est
à peu près normalement on entend aussi
des protestations de militants des
droits de l'homme de personnes qui n'ont
jamais été connus pour leur proximité
avec les islamistes et qui pensent que
la lutte contre la corruption ou alors
les islamistes le terme est pas tout et
que il faudrait qu'à un moment ou à un
autre on est
on est un retour à la normale parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya quand même une
atteinte aux libertés c'est à dire que
quasiment tous les députés sont
interdits de quitter le territoire peu
importe qu'ils soient poursuivis ou pas
et il y a des assignations à résidence
qui qui touchent des personnes par une
auto a déjà poursuivi auparavant et des
personnes comme le le président de
l'ancien président de la commission de
la lutte contre la corruption qui est
par exemple assigne à résidence et
ancien ministre qui sont pas forcément
islamistes qui sont soit assigné à
résidence soit sans aucun contrôle du
juge soit interdite interdit de voyager
donc c'est une situation d'exception qui
n'a pas vocation à durer j'ai dit ça n'a
pas vocation à durer combien de temps ça
va durer le parlement est suspendu
jusqu'à nouvel ordre et me dire quoi
nouvelle heure trente jours de gel comme
ça a été le cas donc du 25 juillet
jusqu'à hier où est ce que ça peut durer
plus longtemps l'issue s'est coiffé des
élections
précisément la première fois au banc
savais que c'était un mois et puis on a
appris que ce serait à moi renouvelables
là on ne met pas du tout 2 on ne met pas
du tout de dette de faim ce que prévoit
la constitution dont l'article 80 qui a
été appliquée quand même d'une manière
qui a en outre passé ce contexte le
l'article 81 parle d'une situation
d'urgence qui peut durer tant que ces
causes perdues et l'appréciation revient
au président de la république donc tant
qu il estime qu' on est en situation de
péril imminent il peut continuer ça peut
durer des mois et après on ne sait pas
on n'a toujours pas on sait pas ce que
pense le président de la république
est-ce qu'il veut carrément changer de
système politique et profiter de cette
de cet état d'exception pour suspendre
la pointe la constitution et ans
promulgué une autre ça c'est possible
mais on met le président le dirai à dos
le seul et ce parcours pour savoir des
choses c'est que dans le communiqué
d'hier il a parlé d'une adresse aux
tunisiens pas qu'il allait s'adresser
aux tunisiens dans les jours qui
viennent et c'est le seul espoir de
savoir ce que veut le président parce
que c'est quelqu'un qui ne communiquent
pas afin qu'ils donnent pas de
conférence de presse c'est quelqu'un
homme quand il convoque des gens chez
lui ddp des ministres ou des
responsables on l'entend que sa parole à
lui et il donne pas de point de presse
et il s'adresse pas à la nation donc
aujourd'hui on va voir dans les jours
qui viennent il va peut-être vous dire
comment ils voient les choses et on va
voir aussi si la société est prête ou
pas à le suivre merci pour toutes ces
précisions un thème nafti
rappelle que vous êtes essayiste et
auteur notamment de l' ouvrage de la
révolution à la restauration où va la
tunisie c'est aux éditions riveneuve